so this all dates back to the Revelation
that Sky News made back in August last
year that the then head of recruitment
in the RAF had resigned in protest while
sources told me was deemed to be an
unlawful order effectively to pause the
pushing of recruits onto training
courses if they were white men in favor
of fast-tracking ethnic minority
individuals and female candidates as
part of this bid this well-intentioned
bid by the head of the RAF to improve
diversity statistics in his Force now
after that Revelation an inquiry was
launched by the RAF it's being led by an
army officer into the circumstances
behind the resignation of group Captain
Elizabeth Nichol and emails that I have
seen have been provided to this inquiry
and they really paint a picture of the
culture inside that recruitment team
historically back in 2021 2020 2020 2021
under a different leader still under the
leadership of course overall of air
Chief Marshals so Mike wigston but these
emails reveal how there was incredible
pressure being put on recruitment
offices to Fast Track to speed up the
flow of ethnic minorities and females to
hit these diversity targets they were
under pressure to increase the flow of
women up to 20 of intake and the flow of
ethnic minorities up to 10 and one of
these emails I can read to you it was
sent from a squadron leader to a
sergeant we're not revealing the names
of these middle management officers that
were involved in all of this but but
this email talks about how there was a
heavy presence of white males on on
these boarding courses a selection board
is when you get a recruit and you you
you Channel them into their initial
training where they learn certain trades
and professions and in this email it
says how the boards recently have been
predominantly white male heavy if we
don't have enough Fame so black Asian
and minority ethnic and female to boost
them then we need to make the decision
to pause boarding and seek more Bame and
female from the recruitment force it
goes on to say I don't really need to
see loads of useless white male Pilots
let's get a get as focused as possible
I'm more than happy to reduce boarding
if needed to have a balanced Bain female
male board and the second email that
I've seen also says that they've
actually that they've actually around
that time January 2021 canceled two
boards because they were only white male
candidates on board now these boards are
important because it's all about
ensuring the flow of recruits into
different trades throughout the RAF
which is fundamental to the operational
capability of the Air Force now the head
of the Air Force has consistently
insisted that his recruitment Drive did
not impact operational output did not
discriminate against white men he has
admitted that mistakes were made
historically but others within defense
do believe that actually unlawful
practices were taking place at that time